foreign
[Applause]
show everybody so it was a little while
ago and to be honest I don't know if we
talked about it on the bonus show or I
talked about it on a live stream but
there was an article about how if you
want to murder someone one of the quote
best ways and by best what we mean Pat
is more likely to get away with it is a
traffic accident and that there are sort
of like special not special rules but
the way that traffic accidents are dealt
with by the criminal justice system
um
it's often sort of chalked up to this
was a driver error that took place
they're not even really looked at as
crimes could be reckless driving
obviously if you're drunk then that's a
different story does this ring a bell to
you Pat did we talk about it on the
bonus show oh yeah I remember you
talking about it maybe a few different
times yeah so we've talked about this a
bunch and uh also on a cruise ship
that's another place where someone and
easily get away with it because you're
in international waters and it's
typically not investigated properly so
there's a new report from NPR that there
are more unsolved murders in the United
States than ever before
and quite literally more and more people
are getting away with murder now I don't
actually know we often have the sense
that if someone were to be targeted and
killed they'd probably be caught between
uh having left having made a mistake
take somewhere left some record the fact
that there are you know toll cameras and
if you rent a car there'd be a record
and you rent it with a fake name but the
place probably has a security camera and
if you wear a mask then they might be
able to follow you back you'd better
have worn the mask yeah we have the
sense that like the person is probably
going to get caught but this really
isn't the case and in fact what we're
seeing across the country is that
Justice isn't being served and that the
United States is increasingly among the
worst in the industrialized world at
clearing is solving clearing
murders and that that raid has now
dropped to below 50 percent in several
large cities it can be as low as the
mid-30 range surprising to you Pat or no
stunning to me yeah if you were to have
me guess what I thought the clearance
rate was for murders I would think north
of 80 percent the fact that it's not
even above 50 percent at this point is
just mind-blowing especially given the
fact that you think that the clearance
rate would increase consistently over
time because cameras are becoming more
and more ubiquitous in daily life and
there's more types of evidence that you
can put forward fingerprints and all
these different technologies that we
have now so the fact that we're seeing
this Decline and that it's not even over
50 it makes me worried it makes me think
that people are going to be more willing
to go out and commit murder given the
fact that there's a 50 50 shot that
they'll be able to get away with it that
is exactly the concern so criminology
experts are saying that this creates a
they call it a doom Loop where both
because there is Miss there's two sides
to this right would-be murderers
unrelated to Prior murders
might correctly get the impression if I
kill someone I will get away with it
that can generate more murders and
secondly
those who are related to the victims if
they come to believe it won't be solved
they become more likely to say I'm going
to take justice into my own hands which
might include a subsequent murder for
vengeance and so in a lot of different
ways that that solving murders is a
deterrent to further murders and not
solving them arguably foments more
murder yeah and it makes me wonder
really what else you can do I suppose
you need more buy-in from the community
to come forth when there are leads that
you have on a particular case but people
get worried about that too because they
don't want to be targeted themselves so
they don't want to be seen as a snitch
they want to see them like they're
mining their own business but if we have
a situation like this where it's really
out of hand I think everyone has to do
their part right and cooperate and it
could mean that we need more resources
more you know time and money spent into
investigating these crimes because it
really does seem to be a deterrent I
mean sometimes we make up what are
actually deterrents when it comes to
crime and some of the things that we
come up with aren't actually true but
solving prior murders definitely seems
to be one it's intuitive in the sense
that uh you know if if people think that
they can get away with it then they're
going to be more likely to do it so we
have to see this clearance rate get way
up over 50 this is another example of
where we really see that the
one-size-fits all defund the police and
Shrink police departments Falls kind of
short and on the one hand I would like
to see less low-hanging fruit low effort
policing of just you know sending a
bunch of officers to certain places uh
setting up to catch Turn Style jumpers
on the New York City subway whatever
else the case may be but the low murder
clearance rate should be a reminder that
maybe for homicide detectives we
actually need to increase funding or at
least to shift existing funding away
from something else or in that direction
the point here is not to say fund all
police departments more but it's just a
reminder that these one-size-fits all
Quote Solutions really don't solve
anything yeah and of course it's a lot
easier to catch the people jumping the
turnstiles or jaywalking or these other
minor crimes tend to clear a murder yeah
you're focused only on the success rate
then it's going to lead you into just
investigating the petty crime but what's
more important to society obviously it's
the the more serious crimes getting
solved and so we just have to reshape
our priorities and um you know you would
think it maybe would be easier as time
goes on but seeing the numbers go in the
trajectory that they are apparently it's
not so easy it's not good it's not good
a federal prisons want inmates to pay
their victims before being allowed to
make phone calls or buy shoes this is a
report from NPR we've talked before
about the often outrageous prices of of
getting access to just phone calls when
one is in prison and there's a new rule
proposed by the Bureau of Prisons which
remember deals with federal inmates most
inmates are State inmates in the United
States this is the Bureau of Prisons for
federal inmates and the idea of this
proposal is that when people on the
outside send inmates money instead of
going to them and going to their
commissary account which can be used for
buying things in a commissary or for
phone calls for whatever the else the
case may be a majority of that money
it's almost like garnished wages would
first Go to paying whatever restitution
debts and court fines the inmate might
have and of course this has a number of
different problems number one
prison conditions are already pretty bad
in many prisons to begin with and one of
the things that can make it slightly
better is having access to some funds
sent by fam friends or family so that
you can make a phone call or get
yourself something at the commissary it
would further degrade prison conditions
which we know the worse the prison
conditions are the more it increases
recidivism and it's just it's a bad
thing and then number two
it shifts the burden of the restitution
for the crime that has been committed to
friends and family which seems very much
unfair now you could say well either way
the burden is on the friends and family
to send stuff so they can get candy bars
okay right but it's a different thing to
say I'm going to help you with what is
the closest thing to groceries that
there is versus I am now going to take
responsibility for the court fines and
the restitution that you might owe that
seems quite unfair yeah that second
point to me is why I don't think this
makes a whole lot of sense here just
shifting the burden and it's not the
responsibility of the family members and
Friends of the inmate to be paying for
that restitution you could say well once
the inmate is out of prison and has a
job returns to society then they can pay
back the debts to the people who spotted
them the money yeah initially but that's
not any sort of guarantee I think maybe
this conversation would be a little
easier if we decided to take phone
privileges away from the commissary
accounts and just you know had it baked
in and as a right that's given to True
inmates because it really should be seen
that way you should have contact with
the outside world you should be able to
talk to your friends and family and not
have that treated as a privilege in my
opinion when it comes to being able to
buy cigarettes if those are still
allowed I'm not even sure or candy bars
or chocolate milk or whatever else maybe
you can have this rule in place for that
but even even so I don't know if I'm all
on board on that and there's also a
difference between the court costs that
get associated with this that get taken
out of the money versus restitution for
victims I think maybe we should divide
that up too one of the suggestions that
prison reform Advocates have been making
is that actually this entire the
restitution and the court costs just all
of it
a payment plan should actually be
established right up front and that
might predetermine what it is that needs
to happen and then it would be
disaggregated from just taking 75
percent of whatever friends and family
send an inmate which is what the
proposal is what whatever people send in
and they might be sending in more or
less on some schedule that we don't know
instead of saying we're just going to
take 75 of what comes in you could have
some predetermined uh payment plan
it could start while the inmate is in
prison now you might say well while
they're in prison they have no ability
to generate income right that is a
problem you know the suggestion is well
they can defer while in prison without
interest some say well you can defer but
with interest like we start getting into
really complicated stuff but the point
would be it is a separate structure from
whatever friends and family out of the
goodness of their hearts decide to send
in that almost certainly should be done
but I still don't think it gets at like
the core issue we're dealing with here
no and another possibility would be to
maybe pay the inmates who are working
jobs while in prison in actual wage
maybe not all the way up to a minimum
wage but something a lot more reasonable
than what they're currently getting yeah
but of course that's ultimately going to
be more of a cost uh to the state that
we're not accounting for just yet I mean
I think that they deserve to be paid
reasonably well I mean they're not as
much as you'd get probably out in the
real world and of course your expenses
are different and everything else I
understand that but if that that's one
way to approach this conversation too
like if they have to raise ten thousand
dollars for uh to uh you know
restitution to the victims that's at
least somewhat reasonable to be able to
save up while you're working in prison I
actually think there's a case that they
should be paid minimum wage that just
being in prison doesn't mean you're
allowed to be taken out of the basic
labor protections but that's a that's a
topic for a different day I think the
concept of what you're bringing out is
certainly an interesting one so this is
a proposal that is being opposed by many
uh we will see if it passes there is a
Dutch man suspected of fathering more
than 550 children worldwide through
sperm donations and he's been ordered to
stop this is 41 year old Jonathan he now
could be fined more than a hundred
thousand Euro if he tries to donate
again he was banned in 2017 from making
sperm donations in the Netherlands after
fathering more than a hundred children
he then went abroad God and online and
now a court in The Hague has told them
he has to provide a list of every Clinic
he's used he's ordered the clinics to
destroy his sperm and he is accused of
misleading hundreds of women now there
are rules in the Netherlands the rule is
no one donor should father more than 25
kids in 12 families and the whole point
of this as you can imagine is that you
don't want a high likelihood of people
who are genetically related and have no
idea to end up getting together and next
thing you know siblings are dating
biological siblings and they have
children together and this is
genetically not a good thing the
argument is the more that these numbers
grow the number of half sisters and
half-brothers can get too big it can
start to cause a big problem it can make
it so that what are we going to need
everybody every couple before having
kids now needs to be tested to see if
they might be related I complete
completely get it it also seems to me I
mean listen some people do this to make
money right some people there are
clinics that pay for donations and so I
can understand hey the more I donate the
more money I make so I I understand that
but still these limitations do make
sense to me even if mathematically the
odds of you coming across and dating
your half-sister or low oh yeah I mean
the odds are low but they're significant
and I think there should be a cut off
point I think it should be well below
the 550 numbers that this man has uh
fathered I don't think that makes a
whole lot of sense to allow him to keep
doing this and so if a fine is what
you're going to threaten him with then
that makes a lot of sense to me it's
just amazing how he would continue to do
this I mean maybe it is the financial
component I looked up that you can make
about a hundred dollars per sample if
you're interested in getting into this
type of thing
so maybe he just Figures it's a way for
him to make some extra money and yeah
it's been working for him for years and
years and so he's going to consistently
keep doing it it could also be he just
likes the idea of having all of these
children out there in the world and
maybe that's how he feels like he's you
know getting his legacy cemented or
something I would this would terrify me
the idea that I have all these children
out in the world and I don't even know
how many same here uh I wouldn't want to
do this myself but Different Strokes for
different folks I suppose because there
is also the misleading component which
we haven't dealt with in what way has he
misled people he has lied when he goes
to some of these clinics about the
number of children that he has uh
fathered and obviously there are many
people who if they knew well I fathered
475 they're not going to want him to be
number 476 so that is the potentially
fraudulent part yeah and apparently he
has a profile that is attractive to
women who are trying to find someone who
is going to Father the child because
they keep choosing him apparently when
there's probably plenty of other people
to choose from but I guess if you do it
enough then chances are you're going to
end up with a lot of takers and a lot of
kids doing this all right so I'm going
to mention something and every time I do
this I sometimes regret it because it
blows up in my face I've made 5 000
donations no no it has nothing to do
with the sperm donor story okay I'm
rescheduled to go back on Lex Friedman's
podcast and it's supposedly going to be
filmed this week I don't know how long
the turnaround is for his episode so I
it might be a day it might be a week
I've just I just don't know on what kind
of a schedule he's filming
um the reason I say it's a risk to
mention it is I was already scheduled to
be on and then very last minute sort of
like by coincidence I found out that he
couldn't do it and he had postponed it
uh good for him that he actually did
reach out about rescheduling it I'm
looking forward to being on I have
absolutely no idea what the conversation
is going to be about he said block out
three to four hours so that's what I've
done but hopefully I'll have more news
about this soon and one of the biggest
podcasts conversation podcast right now
so I'm looking very much forward to it
could be great for the show I'm looking
forward to watching it I hope it goes
better from a conversation standpoint
than the Patrick Bet David appearance
although even though that was kind of a
crap show we still got a lot of new
audience members from it yeah it was
overall worthwhile I think for you to do
it so hopefully this one goes a little
bit better I'll have news for people if
the interview gets recorded I will let
everybody know and then we'll sort of go
from there as far as publication all
right we've got a full week of programs
I'll see everybody tomorrow
[Music]